ils sont désormais des milliers
majoritairement syrien toujours bloqués
à la frontière dans un climat
particulièrement tendu ce vendredi soir
plusieurs échauffourées ont éclaté avec
les forces de l'ordre grecques
des grenades lacrymogènes ont même été
tirés lors des heurts frontaliers
une situation qui dure depuis maintenant
une semaine lors d'un déplacement dans
la zone frontalière
le ministre turc de l'intérieur annoncé
l'envoi de forces spéciales de la police
dans le secteur
objectif empêcher le retour de ceux qui
ont déjà réussi à entrer dans l'union
européenne
cette décision a été prise non seulement
par la grèce mais aussi par tous les
pays européens
elle est claire et nette c'est la partie
grecque qui a utilisé du gaz contre nos
policiers
notre réponse sera symétrique
aujourd'hui nous avons déployé un
millier d'hommes des forces spéciales de
police pour empêcher le retour forcé des
réfugiés de graisse et s'assurer qu'ils
sont traités de manière appropriée en
attendant les migrants n'ont pas d'autre
solution que de patienter et de
déambuler près des postes frontaliers
la plupart d'entre eux sont conscients
d'être au coeur d'enjeux politiques
majeures entre la turquie et l'union
européenne
on nous dit que les frontières étaient
ouvertes et que nous pouvions nous
rendre en grèce
mais la grèce a fermé sa frontière je
pense que c'est le plan d'air doan pour
obtenir de l'argent de l'europe
nous nous rassemblons ici pour traverser
la frontière on nous amène ensuite en
transport dans la vallée nous on peut
aller vers la grèce mais à la frontière
grecque
nous recevons des crimes et nous sommes
renvoyés vers la turquie nous exigeons
que les pays européens ouvrent leurs
frontières pour qu'une puissions quitter
la turquie
malgré des conditions difficiles et une
frontière fermée les migrants ne
désespère pas d'atteindre l'europe par
tous les moyens pour le moment rien
n'est clair nous sommes toujours en
train d'attendre
nous sommes sûrs que nous traversons la
frontière malgré les difficultés
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés malgré
les pluies et le froid la nuit
nous sommes déterminés à atteindre notre
objectif à tous prix traverser la
frontière
si la plupart des migrants sont encore
bloqués en turquie
certains sont parvenus à atteindre la
grèce notamment par voie maritime
ils ont parfois subi des violences de la
part de certains locaux un premier
procès a eu lieu ce vendredi
deux habitants de lesbos ont été
condamnés à trois mois de prison avec
sursis
[Musique]